I'm a mastermind in military achievement
filthy Nazi nurtured in Norwegians
ragdoll games hilarious it doesn't get
funnier than this more rag doll games
please rag doll games it's like a gift
from God
here you go kids more views another
ragdoll game it's made by line full
games which is a Swedish developer so
you know it's gonna be a bomb-ass game
it's called totally accurate battle sim
that looks amazing this is see this is
kind of game where anyone can play you
could literally put a rag doll in front
of this game and it's still funny oh
okay
I summoned which one did I summon I'm
gonna guess these are my guys go boys
get them yeah [ __ ] they got [ __ ] the
useless piece of [ __ ] I bet they're
Irish wine will doing the cannon crew
sending the cat Andrew boss famine six
spearmen what the [ __ ] is the cannon
crew doing fire
I understand it
shoot shy Kenan ass gonna demo your knee
to your she nodded
I love this game
balista but Sir you can't the Father
Panetta ballista we can't afford to lose
another bullet shut the [ __ ] up on doing
the ballista oh wait we don't we can't
afford it that's what I was trying to
tell you shut up okay all right no no no
go to them damn it
has changed my life like I got shot in
the [ __ ] head
for Sweden this game is driving me
insane I love it ooh the catapult to
caterpillars hey pissants Georgia gonna
[ __ ] fire what the hell are those Jesus
Christ man oh my god he comes back this
guy is amazing I'm like the best goddamn
more general Sweden has ever known I'm
like Gustav the second [ __ ] Otto I
wreck [ __ ] I know how to [ __ ] I know
how to kill people
you think we just let Norway be its own
country [ __ ] that it's time to pay back
it's time to give us out of oil money
it's a fierce battle you outfitted me on
eBay
I'll get you for this come back here you
[ __ ] that's right
juergen is going again Jurgen Pierce's
his nipple for Sweden furgus job dan and
Rudolph you'll never stop Jurgen on the
ballista unless you [ __ ] the bullets
that is god damn it oh the suck I have
his [ __ ] sword up his ass god damn
Norwegians in their fetishes man the
Battle of Helsing boy don't make me
laugh you finish scum finish scum I'll
finish you am I finished
no I'm Swedish what the hell man what
are you doing [ __ ] cowardly ass
Finland
he's trying to be a tree thinking no one
will kill him
get him boy what do you do and where are
you going oh [ __ ] easy be deep shadow go
right at him don't go right at him
don't oh my god that worked
oh [ __ ] headshot oh there's a chance
come on boys tonight we dine in Hell
ha
ah [ __ ]
hello
God haha
I've everything down I'm not a Swedish
I'm just a piece of [ __ ] youtuber that
yells in the microphone too much but
I'll be back and yeah I really enjoy
this game I think it's really cool check
out the language description Landfill
games you are making really cool stuff
lately
I appreciate you and as always stay
awesome brush I don't think you're ready
for this but okay are you are you I mean
I flipped it I've seen some the weirdest
stuff out there this cannot possibly
shock me
Riley come on a zombie hole-in-one
fellow man bumpy head